aber ich sehe schon meine ganzen
bogenschützen sind tot oder ich glaub
das wird ein richtig schlechter kampf
ich glaube ich werde richtig verpacken
luca scheiße ich habe aus zu sehen ist
falsche mikrofon ausgewählt während der
aufnahme deswegen ist die qualität von
der von dem sound der gleich bei mir
hören würde nicht so normal wie ihr den
sonst gewöhnt sagt das tut mir leid ich
habe mir gedacht ich trotzdem hoch weil
das video quasi ja also spanier sondern
ich gut aber es ist wirklich hab ein
paar themen angesprochen die mich auf
jeden fall interessieren die in die
kommentare schreiben könnte das heißt
bitte seht über die schlechte sound
quali hinweg das ist jetzt einmal
passiert uns passiert mir hoffentlich
nie wieder und es tut mir leid und jetzt
sehr viel spaß
hallöchen meine lieben ville de paris
und herzlich willkommen zu einem clash
of plants video ich habe ja in minecraft
zum paradies auf kleins maps vorgestellt
und dann habe ich gesagt wenn ihr da
5000 landschaft oder irgendwie 2009
keine ahnung was er gesagt habe dann
kann ich einfach mal so klein slams
planen weil ich das ganze schon damals
sehr sehr oft gespielt habe und die
jetzt über ein jahr gar nicht gezockt
hab weil nach derzeit wird das spiele
ich zu ihr braucht um das anders
aufzuwerten braucht ihr 5 millionen
davon
und da muss man einmal zehn jahre warten
bis man das hat oder man kauft sich das
aber ich hab kein bock dafür geld
auszugeben und blabla deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich nehme das ganze jetzt
mal auf ich habe gesagt die grafik
sollte viel besser sein als beim spring
kopf das video war ich mich da so ein
bisschen mit vfl von wörtern und so ein
bisschen rum geschlagen habe sollte ich
ganz cool sein und die das video hat
mittlerweile glaube ich schon 22.000
likes also ich hätte nie gedacht dass
dieses gleichauf klein so gefragt dass
und ich dachte eigentlich so zum let's
play ist das eigentlich total schlecht
geeignet weil man zeigt er quasi nur das
was man macht und es ist jetzt nicht
wirklich irgendwie sowas wo man so einen
level bestehen muss angezeigt weiter
sondern ja keine ahnung wie man das
irgendwie sagen soll ich mal ganz kurz
kann ich mir den ton machen keine ahnung
naja jedenfalls was ich eigentlich als
mal machen wollte beziehungsweise da ihr
alle meinte di luca
voll geil dass du uns gesagt dass es
jetzt machen möchtest 5000 daumen hoch
ab die locker geschafft die sache ist
halt ich habe bock auf dieses spiel aber
ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll
also ich weiß nicht was ich euch hier
zeigen soll eventuell welche von euch
also ich damit jetzt meine sachen ein
ich kann euch einfach mal erklären ich
das ganze aufgebaut hat wie lange ich
schon dabei bin
in welchen klaren sich schon war et
cetera was ich an dem spiel so mag
und dann ist es quasi so eine klatsche
auf kleins folge weil ihr wolltet ihr
alle sehen welches letztlich bin ich bei
level 52 84 75 wegen falsch gelesen ich
bin 52 und erklärt jetzt erst mal all
denen die das spiel eventuell nicht
kennen wie das ganze eigentlich abläuft
und die sache ist halt es wenn ihr mehr
videos davon wollten schreibt mir bitte
was ich machen könnte
weil ich hätte auf jeden fall bock drauf
ich bin total und kreativ also ich
erklärt euch erst mal ganz kurz für alle
die es nicht wissen was es ist oben
links hier bei wenn ich jemand auf dass
sie darauf klicken
da sehen wir meinen spielerprofil das
heißt wie viele trophäen ich hab welches
level ich bin trotzdem bekommt man halt
beispielsweise dafür mehr volumen
verbessere in voltlage auf der welt
sehen dafür bekommt man drauf gehen oder
dafür bekommt man in erfahrung und
teilweise halt auch die emirates oder
was heißt sie sehen ein bisschen aus wie
m racer rechts am rand dessen diese
teile hier wenn ich immer darauf blicke
damit karten die kann man sich also kauf
und ist es relativ teuer wenn ich mir
beispielsweise 14 stück 14.000 kaufen
will kos 90 euro das ist richtig grad
davon hab ich 604
ich habe drei bauarbeiter da habe ich
mir damals mit denen
moritz von welche gekauft mit diesen
oder wie heißt nichts mehr akte glaube
ich gar nicht so sicher ob ich mir davon
dritten kaufmann hat von anfang an zwei
stücke die man sich so locker kaufen
kann und zum dritten muss man ein
bisschen sparen mit diesen diamanten und
dann sehen wir oben in der mitte hat
drei bauarbeiter das schild das schild
aktiviert sich immer dann wenn man
angegriffen wird also es kommt drauf an
wie hartmann getroffen wird wenn man
irgendwie leicht getroffen hat man
eventuell gar kein schild und wenn man
relativ hart durchgenommen wir die mio
marke halten 24 stunden schild teilweise
ich hoffe ich das richtig auch wenn
irgendwas falsch lage dann bricht ich
mich mit in den kommentaren ich hab das
spiel recht lange nicht mehr gespielt
findet aber ganz gut dass meine welt
gespeichert wurde
ja das ist hatte stellt das hab ich noch
drei stunden weil ich jetzt hier wenn
man mal hier draufklicken sieht man dass
da bei den nachrichten sieht man ihn
verteidigungs locken den angriffsdruck
dass zum beispiel ein letzter angriff
habe ich 98 gewonnen dadurch öfter auf
jeden fall bekommen allerdings habe ich
jetzt hier beispielsweise verloren
relativ wenig allerdings zwei und vier
trophäen allerdings hier sehen wir
beispielsweise 50 das ganze kann man
dann auch wiederholen oder auf rache
klicken also den zurück angreifen et
cetera das können wir eventuell nachher
mal machen dass wir irgendwie zurück
angreifen eine kleine rache üben und da
hab ich halt dann immer verloren wir
können sonst auch einfach mal also das
ist erstmal das menü wir sehen nach oben
rechts noch dunkle felix also gold dann
elixir und dunkel six hier mit dunklem
elixia also dass man alles resorts mit
dem man sich beispielsweise der neue
solarer kaufen kann oder in armee dann
irgendwie mal in barbaren könig der
dunkle kaserne oder bogenschützen könig
oder irgendwie bei verteidigung wo ich
mich sehr speziell darauf spezialisiert
ab was die luftabwehr teile reisen so
ein paar bomben die man dahin stellt die
explodierenden beispielsweise und das
ganze spiel ist quasi seine strategie
spiel wo man seine map aufbaut und ich
will es mal ganz kurz die sachen
die ich hier noch gar nicht eingesammelt
habe als neuen ressourcen sehe ich
gerade und dunkle sexy wie viel ist das
120 alexis ächtung des wegs ist echt
krass
und was das denn eine juwelen kiste
achja juwelen heißen diese teile sowie
ich glaube zwei jetzt alle bauarbeiter
von mir beschäftigt dass man ihm noch 14
stunden kann ohne die wird gerade auf
level 7 updaten und dass wir sechs gab
bildet der bogenschützen turm
ihr seht schon bei mir so wenn man es
mit mango vergleich hier beispielsweise
wenn man sich mal die kaserne anguckt da
kann man halt leute ausbilden da hat
meine weiteste kaserne ist bis zu dem
jahr also die den kz den drachen habe
ich zum beispiel noch gar nicht
freigeschaltet und ich habe halt also
was ihr halt seht da habe ich jetzt die
teile bekommen was ihr halt schon seht
bei mir sehr sehr viel verwildert wir
sehen hier beispielsweise überall bäume
und so das kommt halt wenn man lange
nicht drin bauen aus den bäumen kriegt
man teilweise auch sachen ausgesät er
zum beispiel gleich nach den 20 sekunden
kommt da halt irgendwie was raus wie
beispielsweise ja keine ahnung was
herauskommt teilweise wählen teilweise
nichts teilweise gold heißt gar nicht
erst anreisen ja das ende aber doch eben
das ist quasi wenn die leute dahin
hoffen dass die dann herausgeschleudert
werden ja letztendlich dabei wartet
jetzt sehen wir dass so was rauskommt
also es lohnt sich schon die sachen weg
zu machen damit weil da halt dinge
rauskommen ich habe zum beispiel sphere
juwelen hier gefunden
allerdings ist es halt auch so wenn ich
mal was passiert und dass sie da hin
setze seht ihr jetzt ist das eine weiße
mauer drum herum
das heißt quasi nur außerhalb dieser
mauer können die leute ihre angreifer
spawn also wenn man angegriffen wird
deswegen habe ich beispielsweise hier
immer so das lied quasi immer so einer
richtigen wald um rum
das heißt ich habe die ganzen teile
nicht direkt an der mauer stehen also
nicht so nicht direkt an der mauer
sondern immer relativ außerhalb damit
beispielsweise die leute die mich
angreifen nur ihre teils beispielsweise
hier das bauen kann
da auch in diesem feld und nicht quasi
direkt da drin also hier drin
beispielsweise kann man nicht bauen weil
das ganze ausgeglichen wird dann kann
man nix bonn sondern das geht halt alles
nur wenn ich das mal hier so ein
bisschen welch ein paar bomben zur
abschreckung das geht halt alles nur so
außerhalb und die meisten denken sich
die bomben sieht man nicht wenn man
angreift die meisten denken sich sparen
hier welche weil hier ist ein großer
platz und hier so offen aber hab ich
halt extra offen gemacht und einer 2
pumpen hingestellt dass die gehalt in
der luft gesprengt werden und hier halt
auch relativ offen aber da sind dann
halt auch bomben und deswegen habe die
ganze sache ein bisschen verteilt gebaut
ich habe es nicht so gemacht dass ich
das ganze so zum quadrat gemacht habe
also dass ich irgendwie drin
vier gebäude haben eine goldene mauer
dann wieder draußen rum zwölf gebäude in
seinem kreis also hielt fiel dann die
mauer dann wieder wenn ich jetzt oben
und wieder an der mauer sondern ich habe
das ganze ist ein bisschen so gemacht
und zwar hatte ich sonst immer das
rathaus das ist quasi das wenn man das
zerstört dann kriegt man quasi direkt
juwelen also direkt trophäe
deswegen euch das nach außen gestellt
das macht man wenn man fand hat mir ein
kumpel gesagt und zwar die meisten
greifen halt auch teilweise nur an um
juwelen zu bekommen und deswegen gehe
ich halt direkt aufs rathaus die können
quasi des rates ist hier die können sich
direkt vor dem rathaus hieß porn können
das angreifen und danach ziehen sie
quasi wieder ab weil die juwelen sind
mir scheißegal
mir ist halt erstmal wichtig dass ich
ein bisschen ressourcen zusammen kriegen
weil ich halt irgendwann das dunkle
elixir so ein bisschen mehr bekommen
möchte zum beispiel hier sehen jetzt ist
dieser bohrer das ganze hier bei mir a
produziert dies ist aber alles extrem
teuer und ihr seht halt schon ich habe
mich sehr auf die also ich habe diesen
bohrer direkte nachmittag die lager zum
beispiel mein gold lagert total voll das
als 250.000 gold drin
und hier sind auch alle total voll und
sogar schon der will elfter sind 400.000
gold ist und das wird alle lacht sogar
nur ja jedenfalls habe ich ja die ganzen
lage auch meine elixir lager und dann
halt aus herum immer so diese sachen die
haut angreifen beispielsweise hier eine
kanone oder jene luftabwehr hier die
kanonen wird platt geupdatet der
bogenschützen tu mir auch in magier turm
luft awel zwei kanone level 6
minenwerfer sind die krassesten teile
finde ich also habe ich level 4 54 5
hiernach mitte habe ich halt auch noch
irgendwie sowas wie ein magier atom
level 2 markiert 27
hier auch die bogenschützen wenn man
sich ja damals im klaren wo man die
bogenschützen das seht ihr auch hier bei
der kaserne wenn ich truppen ausbilden
ich habe zum beispiel die bogenschützen
schon auf level 4
was heißt schon also es halt auch noch
nicht weit aber man durfte als erster
den klar wenn man die level 4 hatte das
war so bogenschützen klang jetzt
mittlerweile bin ich gerade in gar
keinem klaren dafür hat man halt diese
klaren burg die das ganze regel da kann
man sich dann halt so
der clan halten also der vorteil an dem
kleines highlight ist die leute dass man
dazu sagen kann leute ich will niemanden
angreifen ich brauche noch ein paar
verstärkung dann können die ein
beispielsweise in drachen zu senden oder
halt ganz für bogenschützen und das ist
eigentlich ganz neu seien die leute
darin unterstützen weil ich halt damit
relativ klein waren im spiel und die man
einfach mal irgendwer hatte mir level 6
bogenschützen gegeben dann habe ich alle
gegner war total platt gemacht dass
eigentlich nur der zeit bin ich halt im
klaren weil ich das spiel halt selber
sehr lang nicht gespielt habe und dann
rausgeschmissen wurde aber ihr seht
schon beispielsweise ich habe hier
goldene mauern in der mitte liegen in
der mitte drumherum
es ist schon eine sehr gute abwehr und
ich könnte die anderen jetzt hat auch
noch updaten als 50.000 dann kann ich
dir alle updaten aber das ist mir zu
viel arbeit ich habe zwar genug gold
dafür was ich habe eine million gold in
etwa nur ihr müsstet mir jetzt halt
sagen also das ist in etwa so circa das
was ich hier mache ihr müsst mir jetzt
halt sagen wie was ich machen kann noch
in diesem spiel und wenn ihr noch ein
video haben wollt was er machen soll
also ich kann jetzt beispielsweise mal
wieder angreifen
bei mir ist es aber so ja wenn man jetzt
den angreifer wird quasi das schild
deaktiviert also es geht jetzt noch drei
stunden aber jetzt wird halt deaktiviert
war ich quasi aus dem schild draußen
muss so ganz grob gesehen
das sollten wir aber eigentlich schaffen
den kirche immer so ich mache nicht so
jahr hier ich jetzt brauche ich ein paar
bogenschützen und hier mache ich dann
die bahn und hier macht den königsborn
alle auf einmal immer das mache ich
irgendwie immer so ich weiß nicht warum
es ihnen angewohnheit von mir weil ich
dann denke dass du die werden dann
teilweise geheilt von auch ich hab gar
keine heiler gerade dabei diese szenen
die einen heilen
ach verdammt jetzt geht der kampf auch
schon hier im moment los ja ich würde
sagen wir greifen einfach mal von ihr
anguckt diesen kampf amir sie quasi
immer so aus ich mache hier noch ein
paar kotproben überall hin weil die
kobolde ja
immer das elixier ausgaben sei nicht
ganz nice da macht ihr diese luftabwehr
dass die quasi direkt auf diese
verteidigung sachen von dem hier drauf
gehen dann kann ich schon mal hier auch
auf die verteidigung sache nicht dass
dieser mann werfe das ist immer ein
bisschen blöd hergeht man er heftig ab
termin werfer der muss einmal direkt gut
gemacht werden da kommt jetzt noch die
leute mit dem bomben ich spreche jetzt
erstmal die mauern damit diese riesen
dann gleich da durchkommen nein nein das
wünsche ich mir halt es diese leute dass
man sagen kann wo ihr sollt da und da
angreifen weil die gehen immer direkt
zum nächsten was sie gerade in der nähe
ist um nicht zu dem was gerade was ich
meine wo sie hingehen sollen aber ich
sehe glaube schon meinen ganzen
bogenschützen sind tot oder ich glaube
das wird ein richtig schlechter kampf
ich glaube ich werde richtig verpacken
ich glaube ich werde heftig verpacken so
ich wünschte das jetzt mal zum rathaus
gehen würden sind nicht es ist ein
bisschen turm weil das ist echt traurig
dass meine ganzen bogenschützen standort
sind das ging relativ schnell aber ich
glaube ich habe doch gar nicht so viel
aber meine kobolde sind auch schon alle
weg weil letztendlich ich meinen tisch
ist mir nicht so wichtig ist nämlich
wichtiger ich habe jetzt einstellen das
heißt quasi erzählt als gewonnen profen
bekomme ich auch also ich denke es wird
relativ eng ich glaube nicht als er
schaffe obwohl halt passen doch diese
kann ohne die die kanone ja denn die das
abi nicht da schauen wir auch keine
das ist jetzt natürlich cool für die
erste folge dass das ist halt dieser
nachteile wenn das ganze leitet
ich hoffe mal die facetime prag nicht
weil dieses reflektor programm und tabak
enthält mega viel
jetzt kann man quasi nur noch zugucken
hätte ich jetzt noch irgendwie mir ein
paar leute aufbewahrt
beispielsweise noch einen zauberspruch
zur heilung wird hier noch einen
hingehauen jetzt jetzt trudelt der kampf
fällt quasi zu ende weil jetzt ist
dieser bogenschützen frieda mich die
ganze zeit am apparat
jetzt gehen die beiden darauf an der
jetzt ist ein langweiliger kampf dieser
zeit setzt euch gefallen hat auf jeden
fall dann drückt auf jeden fall den mag
ich packen weil dadurch sehe ich ja ihr
wollt mehr davon und wenn ihr mehr davon
wollte ja ziemlich verloren also ich hab
zwar gewonnen 60 schaden aber ich hab
meine ganzen truppen verloren ich hätte
echt mehr rausholen können als bin ich
die ganzen leute halt wieder am
ausbilden also ich gehe es
beispielsweise in dieser kaserne hole
mir noch ein paar krieger ich mache das
immer so frei nach laune so von allen
irgendwie etwas aber ich finde das eine
ganz gesunde mischung immer jeden
zauberspruch hier ich brauche auf jeden
fall diese heile dich lieber ein paar
kobolde weg ich glaube die 10 10 10
stück ja da soll sich hier auch ein von
solon hole ich mir noch euch hier so ein
paar teure leute und hier noch welche
von denen so letztendlich bilden sich
diese leute quasi jetzt aus bis sie
ausgebildet sind kann ich dann wieder
ihn angreifen wahrscheinlich in der
zwischenzeit wenn ich offen eingehe
werde ich wieder angegriffen habt dann
wieder in 24 stunden schild die sache
ist jetzt wahr wie halt nur wenn ihr
mehr davon wollt dann schreib mir was
machen könnte eventuell guck dir andere
leute also ich kenne jetzt kein in
deutschland er das so wirklich let's
play
es gibt bestimmt welche aber ich kenne
auf jeden fall kein weil ich mich
darüber noch nicht so wirklich
informiert habe wenn ihr mehr bock auf
mehr clash of planes habt dann zeigt man
mit dem daumen hoch und schreiben auf
jeden fall was ich machen könnte und
dann will ich sagen ich muss jetzt
formiert teppich kaufen und dann sehen
wir uns irgendwann wieder via haut rein
und